僕の名前は大阪品質
今日はですねん
聞いてくれている人がいると
生きる力に出るぞ
そういう話をした
思います
僕は今
自分で新聞を発行しています
みなさんのお家に届くようなたくさんのニュースを持っているようなそういう新聞社は
ないんですけれども
身近な人に
すごくわけで
その人も陰性にスポットライトを当てて
まとめて
月いっ
大切な読者の皆さんの元に
色であります
まだ小さな新聞社です
僕は
33年前
富山県に生まれました
新聞屋さんもそうとしてもらいました
毎朝おじいちゃんのお父さん
50年間
信号があいさつし続けました
お父さんとっても厳しいです
今でも怖いです
おじいちゃんされて怖かった
でもそのおじいちゃんとか大丈夫ですね
きっとこの
誰から見てるよ
最後にん
この言葉で僕のいちばん伝えたいメッセージを皆さんにお届けします
子茶になるこう言われました
大切な言いもんです
道の真ん中歩かれると
確かた執行アルバムん
これどういう意味なんかわかりますか僕今でその意味はまだありません
でも少しずつ
自分で今の授業やっていくことでついたことがありました
初めて姫ちゃんで約束したことがあります
保育園の時に
ピーちゃんとバターがテレビ
甲子園の入場行進を一緒に行きます
僕はその時に
僕はここに世帯でいるからですいます
リーチャーすごく塗りストーンをして
バージョンの顔3 day
それまでは知らしめの予定馬
おばあちゃんすごく病気がちで
でもその時のばあちゃんの
りーちゃんをいただきはいそうですねその一言だけで僕は高校時代まで野球を頑張り
ました
一生懸命野球頑張って
は県の名門高校に入りました
でもその時にを描けない出来事があったのが同級生からの機能です
先輩からの動きだったり厳しい来週
もしくは先輩ラーの豪力だったりそういうのまだ当たり前の時代の野球をしていたので
この同級生のいじめというは車でもちろん経験をしたことがあるし
てもつらいものでしたね
新たに先輩がはの商品をたい理由で僕一人だけ外に出てたんですね
帰ってきたときにこう言われましたなんだ矢先ないんだ
このしたら主犯格のグループ
そのメンバーからの虫からなりました
暴力ならまだよかった話しています
戦いましたん
でもむしろつらいです
火を打って高校の中で白い存在ですから
僕がいじめられるとクラスでも話をする相手はいなくなります
ものすごくつん
入れられた方も悪いんじゃねーかよくなります
この言葉を自分に問いかけて
自分こんなこと悪いのかなこういうところがよくなかったのかな
どんどんどんどん自分を追い込みました
おかげでもっと誰とも話せなくなります
高校1年生の夏
牛続くにある声で
いうと
寝台とったんです
もう森翔平
死んでしまえばいじめているいじめてた
総合 q せー
に返せ
死んでしまえばその小山一生後悔しよう
そういう気分になります
本当にどん底で
そのどん底のところで
じいちゃんタウン試したんです
恥ずかしいけどその場でなりました
私の山言葉です
のおかげで
ということををっ
やりました
ロックにどん底になったのに
人って誰から顔が思い浮かぶんだなと思う
この時初めての誰から見てるっていう経験
を示しています
でももちろんこの時はこういったことだと思いかけません
今だからなかなかです
でも
言ってることはダメならそれだけはありません
兄ちゃんの間は oa かんだそれだけはいつです
と今
1人うつらい思いをしている人のん
いると思います
部からのメッセージは
どこだっけ
大丈夫ですね
納付にどん底までいったら
誰かの顔を思い浮かべますか
重い噛んだらもう撮って大丈夫です
死ぬのはやめたことは
東京西に言われたに解消しようかなと思います
そこで想いていたのはあっ
妖精に初ことです
アイプチ
正直興味ありません
自分ができないになって欲しいにいればいい
東急生と仲良くすることはなくん
本当に今思えばひとりぼっちでしたけれども強いその方の中になりました
地方大会の前哨戦で
ご支援を飼ってらっしゃるんです
残念の春からレギュラーの家具をつけさせてもらったんですけれども
小川は
短命交通と思います
相続いらっしゃいません
甲子園を決めました支援勝ちました
甲子園の次のですスチーム実際に飲みました
でも何でも残らなかった
その頃はなかった時に
三塁コーチャーと僕に光は行ってくれた人が一人だけいます
それが向上し文ちゃん者です
本当に嬉しかったです今でも大事が大切にスクラップしてくるっ
一冊の本に出会った時に僕がこれまでの
1名関する8観が変わりましたも
その言葉が出たんですね
いじめはいじめた側が100%ん
お前はなくないぞと言われた気がしました
おかげでもがこれまで自分の存在を
私がないものだっ
ずっと住み続けてましたけども
この言葉で出会って勇気をもらいました
大学に入って初めて高校時代につらかったことを打ち明ける存在に出会いました
当時もカウントです
今が桜さんです
初めて女の子の前で泣きながら話をしましたん
毎日のように
夢に秘められた時の
映像ができるのですうなされて汗いっぱいかいてー
ベッドガードより
いった病気本当にそんなないんですかね
その時に
一つ気づいたことがあったんです
弱みを
いただけだして
打ち明けるということ
これが強さなんだということに気づきました
それまで僕は入ることが
調査なんだったと思ったんです
でももちろんそれも大事かもしれません
でも今
弱みを見せてさらけ出してその上で理解してくれる仲間にも行ってきました
おかげで今ものすごく幸せです
皆さんもこの心の声です
いけません
人の方へばっかり聴いて自分の声を聞かないというのは
を
行かないんだろうなと思います
山部止まずマスコミで働こうと思いました
新聞ちゃんよねああ
大学もや勘に頼って
入る前
テレビ局でアルバイトをしてでも実際に見る現場は僕の想像する世界とは違っています
そして振動 friday
の親父が唯一認めていただいてい
頭を下げに大抵会計士これを目指そうと思ったんです
ただ
そう簡単には試験にわかりませんでした
それでも
資格がないというコンプレックスを抱えながら
会計事務所に就職し
お金と出生この2つを求めました
同級生をに返すためには給料が必要
この考えです
コンビニって皆さん何を見ます
だし
まんな週刊誌とか書を出し読むと思うんですけど
この頃この頃の僕の価値観でお金ですから
を見に行くと
広げる尺は25歳大企業
埋まる迫る会社
塩員給与いくら
それを見ながら
よし買っている
とんでもないは一瞬
でもそういう価値観と仕事をしてきましたん
でも家が体
限界がきます
29歳の時に役員までのし上がって年収もみんなよりもはるかにもらって
すべての目標を発生したとき
待ったか次の目的や見つかりませんでした
このなく帽子を
考えれば考えるほど目の前の仕事を取らせたくなって
もう国にこいつがかけないでほしい
僕の頭に声がかけないでくれ言葉を入れないけどテレビの音すらやー
そういう状態をあっ通じていました
目的がないと一つ努力できないんだなって
でもやっぱり辛いいけないんですよ
奥さんにも言えないなもちろん家にもいえ
僕の場合は同様にも入れません
もし辛いって本音をぶちまけたずに入っ
同僚から
it 今まで何だったんだ
そういうふうにどういうふうに追われればコアん
辛いって照準に出なかった
29歳の役員になったと言う
イオン立ってい
子供が
3人目の子供ができた頃でしたね
もう限界になって
見えなくて会社に行けなくなって
その時の会社を逃げ出すようにして対処し
少しだけ家族の時間を大切にしようと思っている踏み出した進路が
いを作る仕事でしています
家族の幸せ
この価値観少しだけ僕が近づいた瞬間です
そして運命の出会いになりました
その時の会社で
社長にこう言われました
新しい事業を考え
新しいものを見つけるには
今まで経験した元の中からしか出てこないはずだから
いままでやってきたことをポストイットになって全て入らせておりました
オイペン
学校の先生コンサルティングや加盟
本屋さんん
もちろんその中に新聞社実際
でもその時は生きていけません
ずっと社長から渡された紙がありません
それがこの今の事業のきっかけになる
新聞紙その心を揺さぶるためになる
そういった記事を集めた新聞でした
正直これだと思いました秒やろうと思いました
そして会社を辞めて
力以上作り始めたっ
その時いじめなんてありません
正直一人です
第も見てなります
でもその時初めて経験しましたん
自分自身の声なべきだということです
僕の作る新聞が誰も見てくれないと
届けている何の感動も名
国価値がないんじゃない
その子もんじそうです
これはこれで凄くしてい
その苦しい時に作ってくれからがたった一人の存在です
目の前6の新婚広い4な子が
涙を流しながら
こう言ってくれましたね
出会いと言いましたっ
をズバズバ言うけど意地を張ってくれました
これではだ
言うと思いました
続けようと思いますん
を届けようと思います
でも正直
おしゃれにまたこうし続けたとしてもまた読者の人がいなくなるんじゃないかというの
はもう今でもありません
でもこの時にまた思い出したのねー
おじいちゃんと
お子さんの姿です
広げを広げようと思って一生懸命
妙上を掴もうとします
でもなかなかその56いけないです
やれることって目の前のことだけだと思ったんです
おじいちゃんのお父さんの姿って
50年間毎日一人一人一軒一軒新聞を配る
そんな感じの仕事だっ
これをやればいいと思います
もうおじいちゃんれしてません
でもその姿を覚えて僕もこれをやろうと思ったんです
そこから
一人一人愛にことにしました思いを伝えました
は少しだけ
広がって
その時に気づいたハッピーが
が広げて問題ないっ
だめだもんだ
正直より孤独でもいいと思っていますがは
でもより足元により小さなことに着弾
おいて
進んでいきたいな
今本当にそう思っています
とつだけ皆さんに贈る言葉があるとすればこれかなって思いました
自分にない持ってほしいんですだからどんどん取りに行こうとするんです
相手の勝ツ遊びに行こうとするんですっ
本当に大切なと思っての前にあるんじゃないかと
そこに気付けると本当に新たな可能性大きいんじゃないかと思ったんです
全部じいちゃんや親父の教えてくれたことです
でも今になってようやく気づきました
もう一つ
の前にあるものを
観察して
大切にして
たことが吹くの今からやっていく品する気か誰かなって思います
最後
いう言葉きっと誰かが見てる
本当にどん底になった時預かったらいいかな思い浮かぶと思います
覚え彼が大丈夫です
誰かにとって
たった一人の存在になりたいっ
の方が思います
誰かにとって
たった一人の存在になって
その子は本当に苦しいとき
だれ者に顔を覚えたんでー
そのおかげで少しだけ勇気が出て
生きようって by 盗もうと萌え妄想しか守ってもいいん
そういう存在に僕はなりたいと思って
今年だけ
に最後に伝える
目の前はたった一人を大切にすること
僕にとっても大切にするとはその存在を忘れないということです
小栗国ではこの親父いただいたのはじいちゃんの缶です
父母や続けてくると思います
これを
ひとりひとりの人に具体的
その生き方はあたり
今こうしてこの場合形でもらって
正直全五大草履なんてまったくありません
今目の前にいる僕の大切な
1人この想いを伝えればいいなと思って
いるかもしれません
退院
ありがとうございました